breaking news the bbc is now reporting
oscar-winning actor sean connery has
died
connery is best known for playing the
british secret agent james bond across
more than a half dozen films
he was 90 years old mark phillips look
back looks back
on sean connery's life he must have
played the wrong ball somewhere on the
18th fairway
we are playing strict rules so i'm
afraid you lose the whole and the match
whatever else sean connery did in life
he'll always be remembered for this
i admire your luck mr
bond james bond
1962's dr no was connery's breakthrough
in who was the best james bond contest
he always places at or near the top
yet he wasn't an obvious choice for the
role merely a cheap one
as he told steve croft on 60 minutes
ian fleming wanted cary grant or and
then he wanted
trevor howard you know well their
salaries were taking care of the budget
yet connery became the standard against
which all other bonds have been measured
just like ursula andres was for bond
girls
[Music]
he took an unlikely route to fame and
fortune born to a cleaning woman mother
and a truck driver father
in a working working-class area of
edinburgh in 1930
but he became scotland's most famous son
since robbie burns
so famous the scottish tourist board
turned him into the face of scotland
in an ad for the country as a school boy
growing up in edinburgh i delivered milk
here
connery had joined the navy after
leaving school with a sixth grade
education
after a short stint he moved to london
where
taking part in the mr universe contest
he learned auditions were being held for
a production of south pacific
he got a part in the chorus after a
handful of smaller movies his
introduction to the hollywood big time
came with the 1958 release of
another time another place with lana
turner
oh mark never let me go his romantic
potential was
obvious from the start of no excuses
unless being so much in love with an
excuse
the seven bond movies he did might have
defined his career
but by the time he had resigned his
double 07 commission for good in 1983
he had moved on he co-starred with his
friend michael kane
in the man who would be king i'm heartly
ashamed for getting you killed instead
of going home rich like you deserve to
he was harrison ford's father in indiana
jones in the last crusade
junior don't call me that please
was a defecting russian submarine
captain in the hunt for red october
you will go with the crew the officers
and i will submerge beneath you
and for his tough cop role in the
untouchables in 1987
who would claim to be that it was not
he won an academy award for best
supporting actor
other awards followed including a
knighthood conferred by the queen
and of freedom of the city of edinburgh
not just for his fame
but for his promotion of another of his
passions
scottish independence he became perhaps
its most famous advocate
[Music]
we have waited nearly 300 years
my hope is that it will evolve with
dignity
and integrity and that it will
truly reflect the new voice of scotland
connery had other interests enjoyed from
his home in the bahamas
soccer and golf three that's worth two
goals that's
it skulls he was described by director
steven
spielberg as one of only a few true
global movie stars
but he was more than that he was a
national symbol
and a cultural icon mark phillips cbs
news london
and could dance between comedy and drama
and just he just had it all best bond
to this day that remains true what a
contribution he made for all of us to
watch and to continue watching
and what a heartthrob yeah i know and
that accent